brother it's been too long
half gone brother my name is pitiful
I've been scavenging the internet and I
found this game that I've never seen
anyone else play before I said sure
everyone has played this game it's an
old classic it's a fine wine a fine wine
of video games I'm talking of course
about faded my name is Jeff my name is
Jeff Munn dammit and yeah if you haven't
seen this game before you're supposed to
save the relationship of trip and grace
penny penny penny penny penny Jeff my
name is yes oh I forgot how tight it is
while I go get grace oh man all right
can I can't enter what is happening
help help Jeff has problem walking trips
ass my god oh my god a 8-ball I remember
this will I get trips ass tonight who
knows that is the chance Barris a god
there is a chance okay the goal here is
to break them up I will go for Josh
there's that [ __ ] I would go for trip
song stay away hi how are you Oh stay
away stay away from me demon child oh no
and make yourself at home
okay fine to stay away I'm protected by
their rainbow dildo the sculptor's nope
I used to be so in to collect pot Khan
you're into Hawks okay you love your
sculpt here so much I'm not even allowed
to touch them trick your poker buddies
used them as ashtrays Oh
anyhow Jeff Jeff Jeff I like to look at
tricks ass my name is Jeff
I'll let you flirt with me just one time
cuz we're friends hey come here
sis come here you're hugging me how nice
of you you like that you like that
and after so long I wanna be great
friend when there's a problem
Jeff yeah yeah that's my name
nothing's wrong everything's fine Wow
seeing you again I love saying my name
is a wonderful times we all used to have
in the sexy gun dungeon oh I think we're
gonna need it
Hey look at her [ __ ] face exact okay
Jeff
yes what does this picture make you
think Oh tripped over a friend on the
spot like that in a word what does this
say to you never do
my name is - one word okay yeah romance
ah it says romance god damn it I always
get it wrong great can you go away
yeah JK grace is ugly oh oh oh
someone get that phone where did I put
it is buck how can you Jeff know my name
at Jeff oh it's my dad individually it's
not saying anything it's still ringing
okay he's being annoying as usual just
just hang it up hello give me give me a
hug
well I was awkward are you guys not
going to say anything
you're just Jeff how about guys that's a
good conversation starter okay hi Rick
do you do squats
okay there's no way to communicate Jeff
okay all right I get it you guys don't
want me here
fine I don't care I don't care anymore I
just walked through the door
good game good game
what the [ __ ] happened all right why
don't we try another name see if that's
more productive car [ __ ] cause that
really a name car what up y'all
that's a cool name it's not a name
[ __ ] League of Legends character my
name it car 12 I'm 12
yes I am penny penny penny penny ah
bingo fancies entry pass is it big
sure thing told you confirmed trips ass
confirmed ah here a call just tripped
love me oh my god ha hi how are you I am
so happy to see you after so long
brother it's been too long car wants
hard drives a martini sound
how does oh yeah you are near the kind
of person and self help and stare god I
don't shake em okay I'm just gonna do my
god what are you doing right now
oh well maybe you'd like some juice or
move a bit here haha okay and makes me
remember the last times we all used to
have trap hop oh well thanks
wait that's not a compliment huh you
always have such nice things to say he's
the nicest
oh I'm kissing now I'm kissing JK I'm
getting right ha
that's it you've got a [ __ ] shamisen
gosh you can expect to clean oh you know
let me stay at we can put up with a lot
but we have our limits you know let me
in let kind I'm so bad at this game
ah it's been too long
look I have friends ha look at all my
friends hi how are you I am so happy to
see you after so long you yeah how are
you doing I just asked him that well I'm
asking him to hey um wait you think
Maria
that's right Maria ha ha ha oh you're
you're quite the Kidder tonight trip ha
ha ha yeah eating Maori never afraid to
say anything that pops into your mind
wait you think I'm cheating on grace yes
with me he looks so happy about it yeah
yeah those you uh you're really your
Janek yeah that's my boy I can tell see
how witty nice Kyle no so good on a fake
how do I play there's only so much you
can expect you know that's Christ Jeff
are you are you leaving the room anyway
where's your bedroom I can't remember
what we were talking about remember oh
yeah
I'll line my very very difficult
teachers cries dad the hole right what
do you think
Oh
yeah Jeff what do you say oh my god oh
my god is no scary this game is a
[ __ ] horror game I swear to God
Jesus no no I really think we have this
woman trust me trust me your look at how
beautiful maybe you'd like some juice or
mineral water yeah no we need to open
this I'll have our friend is here we're
going to enjoy ourselves that's all
there is to it
I've been dying to try this Bordeaux for
a long time it's a perfect anniversary
wine is it [ __ ] you [ __ ] shut the [ __ ]
up this bag the [ __ ] up I forgot you
sometimes I feel like our whole marriage
is just for show I don't know what you
really feel Oh where's ya are you doing
can you believe it here I know it's
crazy what I what are you saying to me
god damn Italy I try to reach out to you
I try to be romantic with you but you're
cold and distant I do I really try yeah
what I'm going to ask you something
great okay great let me ask alright okay
I'm ready finally tell me what do you
want what do you want yes or no okay
in a marriage shouldn't one person try
to make their spouse a better person
even if they don't want it what is this
tough one it's a really tough one
um Jeff my name is Jeff you know I've
never wanted anyone but you no no no
burn burned bed I mean no Jeff
you wanted me I know yeah I've had
enough of this [ __ ]
Jeff I know what you're trying to hint
at about me what about what yeah our
marriage you're gay and you want to run
away you want the truth huh yes yes the
truth please great give me the truth do
you want Josh yeah I think the attention
to what you've been saying tonight
thank you finally pushing me
I have been because I know under I
really might friend or not well now your
friend I'm your love I ask you this
yes or no okay really think that
flirting with me
praising grace flirting with grace and
worst of all seeing that letter with
ever-loving success fails to realize
something about myself from all is what
you get in tonight's supposed to add up
some out of something
[Music]
my name is Jeff